j'étais prête au combat j'étais moins
prête au Couteur du je dois vous le dire
mes amis
[Musique]
nous n'acceptons pas la remise en cause
de ceux qui incarnent l'autorité et ce
ne sont pas de simples violences il nous
faut le réaffirmer sans démagogie mais
le réaffirmer avec force et avec
détermination
[Musique]
tisser des peines automatiques plancher
c'est plus la peine de mettre des juges
petite machine avec un beau programme
une belle appli ça ira très bien dans le
cadre de la proposition loi nous
examinons aujourd'hui
certains l'avaient présenté dans le
cadre de leur campagne présidentielle
c'était le cas pour aller répéter Crès
c'était le cas pour Marine Le Pen ça n'a
pas été le cas de la majorité et donc de
ce point de vue là il peut pas y avoir
non plus de surprise quand à notre
position
[Musique]
j'étais prête au combat
d'idée argument contre argument
conviction contre conviction j'ai été
moins prête au Couteur du je dois vous
le dire mes amis j'étais moins prête au
manœuvre
beaucoup de procédures
j'étais moins prête au scrutin public
sur des amendements rédactionnels quel
gâchis mes chers collègues quel gâchis
[Musique]
je pense que le groupe Renaissance a
tort aujourd'hui et il a tort
profondément et la tort pas vis-à-vis du
groupe horizon pas vis-à-vis de
l'hémicycle il attend vis-à-vis des
Français moi je vous l'ai dit je suis
une énervable mais je prends acte et je
n'oublie rien
il n'énervable mais rockinière
[Musique]